the horror movie it is the most popular
film in the country right now it made a
hundred and twenty-three million dollars
over the weekend yeah everyone everyone
really loves this movie except as I said
one group of people this is true some
clowns are protesting the film there's a
new story about it yes we didn't make
that up you are not making that up
they're saying then prove it to the
happiest look of it's the happiest
looking protestors I've ever seen
they're angry but their smiles are
painted on their faces anyway they're
saying the movie it promotes negative
views of clowns so I invited a member of
the San Bernadino clown Club to talk
about their grievances please welcome
butterscotch the clown was in the show
butterscotch so tell us why are you so
upset about the movie it it makes clowns
seem scary and creepy when everyone
knows clouds are sweet and fun okay so
so you feel misrepresented because the
clown in it is a monster that lives in
the sewer and eats kids exactly it sends
a terrible message I even had to update
my website just to let people know I was
one of the good ones take a look okay
there it is okay well now that okay
okay cutter Scott that's uh now that
seems like a really bad idea and I won't
even ask about the tractor plus ever
since that movie came out people freak
out when they see me crawling out of the
sewer okay
now why are you what are you doing this
sewer there butterscotch well let's just
say that's where I go to evacuate the
clown car wink hey guess what the clown
quarry me now what the clown car is you
know butterscotch when you say things
like that you do sound kind of creepy is
it creepy to want to delight children
with my winsome smile
[Music]
[Applause]
my god butterscotch
she said creepy to brighten their day
with my infectious laugh nice catch
there okay
balloon animals those aren't creepy yeah
sure sure balloon animals those are fun
a balloon animal
[Applause]
animals now the trick is to really get
the end of the balloon nice and wet you
know it's it's wet enough butterscotch
No it can never be too wet you really
got to slick it up butterscotch
butterscotch stop it I know you're
trying to make a case that clowns aren't
creepy but you were really creeping
everybody out right now
well try telling that to all the kids
whose faces light up when they watch me
do my funny little clown dance he did
yakamoto
[Music]
yes play it slower you promoter yes
okay that's
he won't eat your kids
[Applause]
you